[Music]
there he is
Thousand apologies hate when people are
tardy it's good to meet you boys
thanks for coming out you'd masturbate
before you got here did you what told
you I don't work with anybody who's
carrying a loaded weapon [ __ ] the small
talk let's play some guns there you're
on a different level now the guy who
represents this merchandise the lawn is
bigger than your whole [ __ ] country
Justine s gorgeous is Ava where you've
put on a bit of white soccer check out
the mooch that's not what he ordered
[ __ ] really
you ordered m16s different weapon I'm
not running a [ __ ] pizza delivery
service keep your [ __ ] together you want
the weapons or you don't want the
weapons
here we go hahaha now we're cooking
we'd like to leave without money and I'm
sure that you boys would like to leave
Italy bits done for the case with your
bed and I'll finish shoot the picture
I'm sorry sir
[Applause]
Chiquita's bring a sniper so that's what
a [ __ ] brain looks like whoa [ __ ] hey
party Marty come on man
I like it God Brahma protection from it
fiction tell me who hired you right now
oh he's got two choices one you distract
him and I'll leave what - you kill all
of these [ __ ] and I leave you
seem like you we can't all be nice girls
the [ __ ] there says there once was a
good man in you
we all find ourselves in lives we didn't
expect prepared for